despite what are your general rules for
raising money for films I mean what do
you advise your NYU students when the
subject comes up what kind of guidance
do you provide them well I've been
teaching in weiu the past 15 years and
the issue is within a film school or not
a film school where you get to - shoot
where you get the money - for completion
to finish your film
I tell people just have to be inventive
and you look under every nook and cranny
to get it done is not there's not
there's nothing I could tell somebody
that's gonna be like the golden trail
and you're gonna find a pot of gold and
you know at the end is that's just not
the way this industry works so there's
no set roadmap but I'm wondering is
there a certain mindset
are there certain characteristics
whether they're temperament whatever
that you tell someone well I think that
when you want to mean looking for money
you get to have that be tough tough as
nails and not be deterred by nose all it
takes that one person at one grant that
one scholarship you know money can show
up
and fall out of sky sometimes I mean
that's nothing something that that you
have to wait for what am i one of my own
most favorite quotes is by Brooklyn
Dodger owner Branch Rickey who signed
Jackie Robinson and the code assists
luck is a residue of design so if you're
working and busting your ass you better
chance of luck smiling down upon you but
you're just chilling and not extend any
injury excuse not extended any energy
don't get it but go you're not we're not
seeing that elbow grease we're not
seeing initiative when I seen that blood
sweat tears very rarely will you find
yourself in a lucky situation speaking
of which but you can't depend on luck
though you can't depend on luck I've
been very lucky be honest when I decide
when we filmmaking there was only one
african-american director work in
Hollywood his name is Michael Schultz
director of my favorite films Cooley
high and so when I would tell my African
friends you know they're like
to black people they let black people
direct films and so if I never ever
thought about the odds by the time you
think about stuff like that it could be
a self-inflicted paralysis but I knew I
wanted to do and I was committed that
through hard work God willing something
will break my way and it happened
you